an der theresianischen militärakademie
in wiener neustadt findet dieser tage
der militärischen fünfkampf statt
harris sportlerinnen aus sieben nationen
kämpfen dabei um beteiligen
am donnerstag wird das
hindernisschwimmen ausgetragen mit einem
besonderen fan im publikum
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
feuert unsere herzsportler kräftiger
[Applaus]
besondere disziplin der militärischen
fünfkampf der wirklich er zeigt was
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten kennen
und wenn man den bewerb jetzt gesehen
hat beim hindernisschwimmen diese
spannung am schluss was wirklich um
sekunden
[Applaus]
mit 27 6 sekunden setzt sich die
österreicherin cornelia roth durch und
schwimmt damit exakt die gleiche zeit
mit der sie 20 19 neuen österreichischen
rekord aufstellt ob das anfeuern der
ministerin noch mehr und da ist uns
zuschaut weil das passiert nicht jeden
tag und umso mehr wollten wir halt auch
zeigen also immer wenn es die zeit
erlaubt er wie eine mit abreisen und
wenn es hilft ja und wenn wir damit
unsere sportlerinnen sportler anfeuern
kann dann werde das jedenfalls duo viel
wichtiger ist aber dass wir dieses wesen
dieses militärische sportler ist so wie
wir das im ressort haben und das ist
wirklich vergleichbar besser als in
vielen anderen staaten dass wir das
weiterleben und ausbauen unsere
sportlerinnen und sportler unterstützen
und wir haben so viele großartige
trainer bewerber die damit arbeiten und
nur dann sein wie gesagt solche
leistungen möglich und einmal mehr zeigt
sich die bedeutung des sports denn ohne
militär
kein fünfkampf dieser form unsere
sportart militärischen fünfkampf gibt es
so in der form außerhalb des
bundesheeres nicht deswegen wäre das
ohne den bundestag überhaupt nicht
möglich
ideen